look who is joining us right here in
person one of my favorites well done
with sebastian maniscalco
i approve this show i was on it i better
approve it and nobody does this tour the
upcoming tour dates you can go to
sebastianlive.com for all of that good
to see you sebastian maniscalco good to
see you uh always nice to come in here
uh
before we went on uh
the energy in the room was palpable
we gotta get it going like
you can tell when you
when you're in a room that has no energy
right like i walked in it was awake
there's only four of us here what do you
want i know but i mean something you
know i mean some hustle and bustle there
we go
um ladies and gentlemen sebastian
[Applause]
is that better that's great
thanks for coming on i appreciate it
there we go everyone here see his tour
dates uh so i don't even know where to
start with you you were at the uh okay
you were at the rams cardinals game
correct this past week i was there i saw
that you were there
you took a picture and um i haven't been
to a professional football game since
soldier field 1981. are you serious yes
set in the end zone seats january minus
seven uh brought our own food
um
what did it mean you brought your own
food you brought your own food for the
pregame or into the soldier field
you know we weren't gonna go to the
concessions my dad wasn't gonna pay uh
football prices for hot dogs so we uh we
snuck in our own uh our own lunch
um
and uh
i was in a sweet
um not on this day in soldier field no
no this was at the rams game you're
sebastian man
[Music]
yes um and it's loud i mean yes
it is does there need to be all this
activity at a football game it's
different the game presentation has
changed since 1981 yeah when you brought
your own food to why who was the
quarterback in 1981
who was there that day but the game
presentation has certainly changed since
that and i don't know if you're aware of
whose house it is
it's ram's house or is it our
i don't know but
by by the 19th time in the first drive
that they asked the question it's kind
of a rhetorical answer right fellaini
was the backup in 81 vince evans vince
evans yeah i'm sorry that wasn't a
january game uh there was no football in
january but this must have been december
uh
1984 85 is just when they started
thinking about playing january games but
you know yeah i know it's uh it's a
different game presentation now
dj yeah they got a dj they got uh
pyrotechnics
that i can't even have a conversation
there's a speaker right there constantly
with the music it's like a club yes and
uh
yeah it was it was cool but i mean it it
looks beautiful it means the stadium the
way it's laid out looks like a movie set
yeah so who's you who's the friend of
the team that you uh jj watt
uh to the game i've been friends with
him over the last what eight nine years
so i was there with his parents
and were you an honorary what
i was
on monday night sebastian watt
what's your what's your middle initial
jay sebastian j so you were s jaywalk
yeah sj what sj no jersey by the way i
uh i didn't
i didn't wear no you can't jersey i i
don't get i don't get that we have a
rule sebastian maniscalco that you may
not wear a jersey
of
another human being that's younger than
you
you can't do it on
unless you're like 15. you know what i
mean or like why would you do that you
know you could you gotta you gotta wear
a jersey like you could wear a vince
evans jersey you know what i'm saying
but you can't you're not gonna be
rocking a justin fields jersey walking
around you also you know we it it's it's
a problem what we have here about jersey
wearing something yeah i um
that's our issue
i noticed the people that are getting in
fights at the game
are always in a jersey
right you don't see two guys in suits
going at it
on the mezzanine
you know so uh
i like to stay away from any type of uh
phenelia this is amazing i love it i
mean that j.j watt that is so cool um
can you put up the photograph that steve
mariucci my colleague when i said that
you were going to be on this program
he provided me a photograph he went
backstage that's steve with you and joe
montana that was uh this is so special
tonight yeah i mean it's very nice i'm
getting to meet a lot of my childhood
heroes
as i do stand-up and people become fans
of what i'm doing so to see montana and
mariuch backstage
uh
it's not montan it's not montana
i think me and mariuch are on that level
montana and i are you know it's more of
a
respect montana more than mariuch
[Music]
that is so cool though they'd be back
you do a gig you do and then joe montana
comes back and tells you how much he's
enjoying it
they were great and
it's like i don't know what to say a lot
of the times you know it's it's kind of
oh yeah what am i going to say the catch
i mean
what do you say to these guys you know
actually montana was uh was rattling off
pizza recipes he's uh he's a big pizza
guy okay he's talking about making some
pizza um
but yeah no it's been uh it's been fun
that is so cool
and so you are as we all know well done
with sebastian maniscalco streaming now
on discovery plus i had a blast with you
uh this summer when i came and i hung
out with you and i made
an awful mistake
on that day
i thought it was indoors we shot it
outdoors yeah and i wore like a sweater
i came straight from the side as you
could see i wear sweaters on this set
it was like a million friggin degrees
outside well no you came sweating and i
said
i said you want to get some makeup in
here the guy's beating
and uh we had a great time that was fun
and when i got
an offer to come on this show and i
believe and you guys could correct me if
i'm wrong there is is there there is a
zoom option right
[Laughter]
there's a zoom option and i said
scrap the zoom option
i'll drive the 38 minutes
to come in studio
right
yeah there is a zoom option
there is a zoom option you get a lot of
people that come in i think they're
taking the zoom option
you know what there are some that i just
i just want to see you know what i'm
saying yeah some have taken a zoom
option more often than not you know
these days you know i feel like the
chemistry that is going on right here
and now you can't get overzoo
okay
you can't get the type of simply out
here simply can't simply can't now that
room is like it's dead the zoom rooms
are dead the green and the jacket
wouldn't pop you wouldn't zoom no no you
gotta get i gotta come in here i s i
gotta smell eisen's cologne
when i do the show
oh
the musk of eisen brought that round
that's a good that's a good fantasy team
name right eisens musk right the other
day we got what trubisky victory
formation that was a good one that's a
good fantasy jalapeno fall guy yeah we
don't we write them down these things
just come out we have no idea of the
context or anything
you got to have a guy right thank you
thank you it's good material
so sebastian uh one of the many reasons
i also wanted you to come here in person
is to thank you
uh i wanted to thank you greatly because
um i noticed uh a theme to this year's
college football season
i noticed um
michigan um having won an incredible
season and i saw
that uh you picked games on college game
day yeah for michigan versus ohio state
and when i saw you
pick the game that day i was very very
very nervous i mean because you know i'm
i'm on edge about michigan and ohio
state to begin with but i saw you there
it comforted me because i saw you were
in columbus ohio back in september yeah
and you went to ohio state's practice
correct yes okay hung out with ryan day
and there you are wearing blue
on ohio state
practice
okay
this is again
yeah something that uh i'm unaware of i
know that there's a rivalry but i don't
like when i'm when i'm putting on the
clothes i don't go oh i shouldn't wear
this it doesn't really occur to me until
i get there and they're like you're
going to have to take
you're going to have to take your shirt
off
[Laughter]
well you know it's you're wearing blue
and i go yeah yeah i'm sorry you go now
you're gonna have to leave
so
they take because yeah they take things
very very seriously um and let me ask
you you being a sports guy i went on
this college game day yes and i don't
know uh guys have we chit chatting no
there's no that's
that's my new jersey guy he's
getting the phone what are you doing
what are you doing over there
comedy
we're working here what is happening all
right this man could have chosen the
zoom option yeah and you know i treat
sebastian maniscalco like that
no you can't even get a drink at the
table
i'm sorry do whatever you're doing it's
it's
it's not distracting or anything
whatever no one is
[Laughter]
because to be honest with you before you
get to the game day stuff you wore blue
at ohio state practice
then they lose to oregon yeah right then
you show up picking games at michigan
ohio state michigan finally beats ohio
state
yeah you sir
are the man yeah i am you're the thread
you're the common you're the through
line here
and i just wanted to thank you oh you're
welcome thank you um
and i apologize for the behavior it's
all right all right it's okay i'm sorry
i've never
by the way i don't know what you're
doing but is that is that a crest white
strip you got going on or is that just
the teeth
they're beautiful
ask them how much you paid for those
cost a couple bucks oh okay yeah
that's not even yours
all right
what's going to say these were bought
paid for
you're picking games on college picking
games on college game day and i don't
really know football it's not like i'm
going in there and i got like a like a
sheet of
x and o's and i just kind of made it fun
and i got ripped to shreds
because
i went on there and i made fun of my
picks you know
is this ripped you to shreds people
people you know why you having this guy
on they don't know anything about
football you invite a comedian on a
sports show i'm going to give you laughs
right i'm not gonna give you all this
guy's hurt he's got an ankle
you know
[Laughter]
so
yeah um is that is it did i did i shame
the show you didn't it's just there's
too many serious people out there
who i think put hard-earned american
dollars on whether iowa state does in
fact come within a field goal or two of
their opponent and might respect you and
your comedy
uh to
think that that then translates to your
acumen on who wins and by how much
and they just have a little bit of a
little weirdness to it all right all
right
but welcome to our world essentially
yeah when was the last time you were
heckled
uh like
because you play these big places now
people aren't going to be screaming at
you yeah it's it's not hackling it's
more like uh like ch chatter i heard you
heard that like yeah i always hear like
it could be 20 000 people and they're
all laughing and one guy's looking at
his phone and i'm like guy
really so i'm always honed in on just
the littlest of distraction so uh i'm
not heckling not so much get heckled
online okay
all right so how did you wind up picking
games then how did that work coming out
i got the sheet the night before and i
thought okay i think they're good
i didn't go and look at records who's
injured
you know what what by the way what
happened to the fullback
just in general are you using the
fullback the i formation i was looking
at the game last night yeah oh no and
the fullback is no longer well the 49er
if you went to the 49ers game against
the rams a week before you'd seen one
okay you'd have seen one there
but that's correct it's
gone the way of the fullback a lot's
changed since 1981. well i mean you know
i'm a matsui guy
i was wondering what happened to the
tom rathman those types of guys yeah you
know yeah
yes
the tom rathman type guy they're no
they're there's not many of them anymore
just only a handful of places so you
know
you know i got a new guy who you got
this i think his name is uh i forget his
name number 19 on the on the 49ers debo
samuel oh
that's a grown ass man this is my new
favorite guy
plays wide receiver running back i like
a utility player yes sir um yeah i
thought dennis gentry was that guy for
the bears at 85. a little smaller in
size but i felt like he
didn't utilize him on the running back
enough as far as i'm concerned but what
do i know i'm wearing a green jacket
here's what you should do you should
create this new show where you
argue and complain and [ __ ] about
sports problems from 1984 85
as if it's the current day right now and
just treat it like you know what if
there was a sports show back in 1984-85
i think we just maybe workshop something
right i like that idea i like because
that's that's where my interest kind of
fell off in 85 after that
yeah i used to be in on the stats i used
to read the daily herald they grew up in
chicago used to read all like sure who
who who was the top wide receiver you
know all that stuff what about jordan
years i mean you gotta be into that
stuff too right well yeah but i'm
talking football okay jordan obviously
after 90 what 99 i i fell off with
basketball so i got really nothing to
watch
until you know now you got your own you
got your own world going on right now
so you got your own stuff going on yeah
i got my own stuff but i need like a
like a a team
oh the bulls are doing pretty good this
year yeah they're not bad yeah they're
not bad is that world is that a world
cup trophy
all right so this is better than the
zoom option so you can't pick stuff up
i'm coming in i i think i you should
require everybody to come and see what
you're trying to do right yeah we just
swab you and then we come out you do
your thing and yeah
if i was positive would i have to leave
that
right there
is what we call the zoom option
that's where the zoom option comes into
play sir yes
upcoming tour dates he's going to
syracuse chris hey you went to syracuse
oh okay yep uh we have no connection in
milwaukee minneapolis san antonio austin
march 5th and then the forum march 5th
right down the road wherever you were
last night
so
[Music]
we couldn't get into the parking uh lot
yes last night i guess and jj didn't
give you parking no we got it but the
thing wasn't working so i had to point
over to the forum
billboard
[Applause]
that's me and they told they told me go
around
keep it moving that ain't you
by the way the only other person who
could have done that last night was
chris martin because the only other
signs are like cold plays coming on
april 26th
that's it you and chris martin were the
only ones who could have pulled that
that's it with parking last night
you know you're playing a forum
look at that sign
get me in fantastic
i deserve to park here please
uh
sebastianlive.com anything else you want
me to bring up
no i just one one parting uh story if i
could place i don't know if this is
gonna get edited out they won't be um
last night my wife i went with another
couple and uh my wife doesn't walk
at the same speed i i walk
uh so it was nice to have another couple
because she had another woman that she
could kind of lollygag now we're exiting
the uh the stadium
my wife walks so slow that she's getting
hit on
by other guys that's how kind of far we
are
so i turn around and some guy's hitting
on my wife
so i had to come over and make i don't
get into fights i'm not that guy uh so
we got to kind of defuse the situation
where i go babe come on and the guy's
like oh she urged this and then he's
like and uh
and uh
you know what this story in my head had
a better ending
i got nothing over here
scrolling instagram that's what he does
this is what he does
that's his job is to do social media he
can't stop he's addicted to his
screening
don't worry about it i just kind of blow
off those situations there's a lot of
guys especially coming out of a football
game amped up on testosterone that might
get involved in an altercation but i
kind of defuse
uh those types of things with humor and
i'm just recommending uh your audience
to maybe go the humor out they should
try that right so
the question i i have a couple questions
here so what is this distance
by which
you can lose your wife to somebody
hitting
15 yards 15 yards
no more than three to five yards you
should be away from your wife at any
time
when exiting a sporting event
that's the rule that's the rule right
okay otherwise then it's on you it's not
me it was my fault okay um but
doesn't your wife also realize
that when you are leaving a sporting
event in los angeles california
um
that the lollygagging could wind up
being a half an hour mistake 45 minute
long mistake i mean like this is right
you got it have you exp have we like you
need to come up with a chart of her
miles per hour
translating to the number of minutes
extra delay of you getting home and out
of the facility like maybe that would be
helpful your your commentary on this is
dead on but my wife
would walk the same way
if the house was on fire
it's just no urgency
so uh no it's a very slow
that's gonna be a costly mistake
i mean very
costly mistakes we need to get next-gen
stats it's like a new next-gen stat of
how far you are
walking out of a sporting event away
from your much better looking half or a
sports science do we need to get brink
assignments could be something like that
and then and then you have to translate
it to
you know because i'm assuming again the
final score
was it was a total blow what was it i
forget now thirty four eight or
something like that three four eleven
yeah um so
i'm thinking your late third quarter
exit early fourth quarter
i was there with another couple i didn't
want to spoil their evening i would have
left at halftime
but like you know third quarter i'm
starting to chirp hey guys maybe we
should get out of here
and they're like no no let's just stick
around i'm like all right and then uh we
left at
fourth quarter with 412 on the clock
way too late and we were in that like
kind of mass exodus
everybody up the escalator you know
that move where everybody was starting
it was it was a little too hairy for my
uh liking but you know we were there
with another couple we wanted to
the good news is that you know you could
have been on time for your march 5th
date for the forum yeah you know
we're right there i don't have to go
anywhere um
sebastianlive.com for all the tour dates
thank you for not choosing the zoom
option i absolutely appreciate it let me
know anytime you want me to come in here
i'll uh i'm right down the street 43
minutes
at sebastian comedy on twitter and
instagram i follow you should as well
and check out again on discovery plus
well done with sebastian maniscalco i
i'm up here on the show as well thanks
for coming on bro you got it
sebastian maniscalco right here on the
rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here